it is great honor for me to address the
world leaders forum here at the Columbia
University so few words before I start
because it's always a pleasure to visit
the USA but during the last two weeks
our thoughts have been with you because
of serious damage is caused by the
packaging Katrina even we have thought
of you quite mats on behalf of myself
and of the people of Finland I would
like once again to express my
condolences you the loss of the human
lives feminists also participating
already in the rescue effort by
providing autistic experts and other
assistance so it is and gentlemen the
word is one the United Nations has
proved its importance over past six
decades with the major events summit or
I just heard today that the latest
compromise which is going on they said
that its high-level plenary General
Assembly this is one of the compromises
now but if I say the major events amit
sadh never mind it's the same same
summit anyway so we are about to start a
new chapter in the history of the UN the
prologue of this was created at 2000
millennium summit and I still remember
the very special atmosphere of the
summit as the president of this General
Assembly in this meeting I wasn't very
careful with the speakers and what was
said and promised and they body language
and I really had sincerely the feeling
that that was something the united
nations millennium declaration is a
truly fundamental and far-reaching
political commitments for peace security
and development the millennium
declaration at the Millennium
Development Goals we're approved
unanimously then MDGs as we call these
goals ambitious and rightly so the
primary aim is to radically
reduce poverty the UN conference in
Monterey in 2002 continue the work and
agreed on means for financing
development in the same year United
Nations summit in your harness book
focused on sustainable development and
combined the first time very visibly the
social dimension and ecological issues
so we have the nature and we had a map
and now I say Vega seriously that there
is no need to change these political
commitments or lower the ambition to a
great extent agreement has also been
reached on the means to use to be used
in order to achieve the goals and like
stiglitz that's mentioned so as a part
of this work and to see means for
further globalization the ILO ILO
international aid organization appointed
in 2002 a word Commission on the social
dimension and cobble I say sir so the
ILO finance it but it was an independent
work commission so dear friends many
good things have happened but the
timetable for attaining them MDGs the
ghost is in many respects lagging behind
the expectation set at the millennium
summit in two thousand and yet it is
simply a question of transforming
political commitment into action and
implementation in theory very simply
issue we have the capacity as I
mentioned we have the knowledge and we
have the resources and the goals need to
become a natural part of the
implementation of so-called domestic
policy objectives and of the national
democratic responsibility this is a
challenge but at the same time of course
we have to see the international
dimension of the situation and that's
why globalization is so important
cobra season is a mega trend that has
some decisive impact on development and
people's lives all over the world and
people feel that the possibility to
govern day everyday lives is weaken the
word Commission had this support
Commission what's ticket mention had
really 24 members who represented
briefly said a broad variety of use I
have said sometimes that from davos to
porto alegre three of the members were
Americans and they've used an expertise
in to install so strongly to our work I
am already sure that you were aware that
Professor Joseph Stiglitz was one of the
American members the other two way and
mcafee in kogan logos who was the former
US Secretary of Labor in on parents
Republican and a businesswoman and the
third one was John as Sweeney a famous
trade unionist and the president of that
afl-cio so really quite a different kind
of opinions already from USA so somebody
has said that this word Commission was
originally a group of not like minded
people they were just chosen because
they have a different kind of opinions
but nevertheless this commission reads
the consensus on its final report a fair
globalization creating opportunities for
all so which kind of the report it was
them the message that the word
Commission is critical really critical
but yet positive globalization continues
to have an enormous potential for
improving people's quality of life but
at present that potential is not reused
not enough people are benefiting
too many are suffering or entirely
excluded from globalization and it's
then unfair therefore globalization can
and should be reformed the success of
the word Commission report reinforces I
think the fact that we must never fall
into the trap of one truth we we cannot
think that we'd system the only thought
globalization has a very different
meaning to people depending on their
personal experiences people live the
everyday lives as part of a local
community and a nation even in the time
of globalization fur globalization means
more focused on people and on their
needs nation states are still the main
actors in globalization the quality of
global governance depends to a great
extent on day actions the way in which
states pursue their own business has an
impact on whether people benefit from
Kobol ization or whether they are spared
from its negative effects a strong
democratic state that respects human
rights and the rule of law and applies
good governance and social justice
creates a solid foundation for the
actions of individual citizens
nongovernmental organizations and civic
movements are needed to support all this
and they must be able to play fully
devil be free in that way in addition
the business those who normally are
proponents of globalization also should
hold social responsibility in
globalization alongside the nation
states we need regional cooperation such
as the European Union and other
cooperation organizations now already in
Asia in Latin America even in Africa and
then of course we need a Copa
cooperation the commitment of nations
states to multilaterals general values
and shared goals the awareness of the
impact of cross-border activities and
the commitment to solidarity essential
for the quality of global governance I
believe that efficient implementation of
the millennium development goals will
help the developing countries join in
cooperation and vice versa more
efficient governance and a fair goers of
globalization will turn into a means to
attain a millennium development goals
mdgs so the audience each country has
its own history and no model can be
transferred directly to another country
I think that you have heard it many
times also at this in this building but
however the basic components of
development are the same the very same
in the north and in the south in both
developing countries and more developed
countries and we have also agreed in the
UN these components but how old is what
I'm now preaching works in practice so
allow me to present one example and not
making the others guilty I take my own
country within half a century finland
has developed from a pool and remote
country to the prosperous and stable
society and those of you who don't
remember but finland is it's the most
far foremost corner of the europe
neighbor to Sweden Norway and Russia
with a 600 years under the Swedish king
and 100 years under the Russian shark
after that when we became independent
not quite half an half a century ago not
not quite and sensory ago so we have had
since that one civil war and two other
wars
and the climate is still the same so
that's it but what we have done then our
Nordic welfare state model is based upon
a social justice and equality we have
main investments in health care
education and equality Finland and the
other Nordic countries often come out on
the top in the international comparisons
whether these concern competitiveness
the stability of the public economic
education the equality between men women
and men efforts to reduce poverty
absence of corruption or the level of
sustainable development and also this
university have made some studies in
this these comparisons so I think that I
can say that this kind of the Nordic
welfare model has proven to be just and
competitive then let's go to the
regional park a membership in the
European Union means economic and
political security for Finland mutual
cooperation helps the individual member
states exceed the European Union strives
to promote growth employment and
competitiveness in a social fair and
sustainable manner these objectives are
set down in the so-called Lisbon
strategy this strategy is one model just
one model for ambitious regional
cooperation that can promote better
governance of globalization so anything
negative on that yes unfortunately the
Union and the member states have not
implemented the strategy if as
effectively or unscheduled in all
respects and that's why we have also
difficulty still in employment and but
this is a challenge and how task to
accomplish but I'm very happy and proud
to tell you that it is possible try to
see the schedule and to see how it works
but it is really to action an
implementation so it is and gentlemen
the volcanism focused on how the
consequences of
mobilization can be taken into account
in policymaking usually discussions on
globalization concrete only on economic
factors like growth inflation interest
rates economic deterioration or market
access important issues of course but
employment is a key means in eradication
of poverty therefore also employment
should be made into a global goal I
think it's not too much to ask to have a
decent job which brings a livelihood for
yourself and your family a decent job
and however far too many people that
just can dream about it if the
employment impacts of economic policy
decisions would be systematically
assessed that alone might bring
improvement in this situation we also
need to do more for the equality between
women and men we cannot make a real
success in reducing poverty unless the
position of women is improved they are
the majority of the goal not minority it
falls therefore that mainstreaming
equality in all activities is crucial an
urgent goal and you can be sure that i
will repeat this also in un alternate
routes and coherence of global policies
inclusive for controlling the negative
effects of globalization international
organizations must be willing for
cooperation and welcome its others
particular sense I have in my mind for
example the need to improve the
coherence between trade regulations and
the development agenda very often what
we had such done with the development
agenda will be sports or made very
difficult with trade agenda so for you
now
we have been gathering feedback on the
word commission report and I have I have
been faded a bit surprised by the amount
of interest in the report and people's
willingness to discuss its
recommendations I believe that our
report is becoming part of the process
of turning globalization into a fair
process that creates opportunities for
all I think that mrs. stieglitz and I we
do remember that we all were wondering
in the commission that one thing is is a
mech is to make a good report but even
more important thing is to make a port
to be a part of the process because the
world is full of the reports good papers
but the process action the
implementation is what we need but
people's can help in that so what's
what's now with this paper the African
Union has assumed the recommendations of
the word Commission as a part of the
globalization work the social dimension
is globalization is also high up on the
European Union's agenda last December
the united nations general assembly
unanimously approved a resolution
whereby the report of the word
commission was approved as one of the
basic documents for this UN major event
or whatever was the name today in
addition the topic has come up to both
the word bank and the OECD so that was
very good but as I said report is a
report we must concentrate on creating
means and processes to reform
globalization and interns its direction
finland and tanzania hamp together with
friendly governments initiated the
Helsinki process last week a conference
took place in Helsinki as a culminating
event of the Helsinki process the key
message of the conference was the need
for the mouth multi-stakeholder
cooperation info
finding lasting solutions to global
problems the ultimate aim of the
Helsinki process is to make
multi-stakeholder cooperation a
permanent feature of global governance
so we old fellows in that way president
of Tanzania man mr. been a mimic up and
I we were co-chairing this commission as
it was a discussion we participated in
the confidence and we're very happy to
see the man consequence of the process
so far for the future all interested
parties are welcome to join the Helsinki
process and already now there are
several countries which are trying to
make the Helsinki quantum success as
well-known as one other con censorship
so ladies and gentlemen this year the
United Nations is the focus of
celebration but it is also the subject
to the critical assessment the world has
changed and the security threats are
different nevertheless the United
Nations Charter represents the values
that will enable us to preserve security
and stable conditions in the future
world as well as balanced development
all countries both great big ones and
the small and poor ones they are needed
in the international cooperation that
will ensure development security and
human rights and when I'm now here in
Columbia University i want to say very
strongly that this international
cooperation particularly needs the
participation of the united states of
america you its political and economic
power you its many resources so
I hope you will be among those people
who will make this wish of mine too I
have high expectations for the UN major
event it is a unique opportunity to give
a new vitality to the United Nations and
the implementation of the millennium
development goals I still hope that we
will be able this week to the enforce
people's belief in the future and that
we will be prepared to openly
acknowledge existing problems including
the lack of the political will or the
unfair distribution of the resources
multi-lateral work is needed in order to
strengthen fair processes of development
so finally I would like to highlight one
important recommendation in the word
Commission of the globalization report
in particular for the benefit of view
dis audience police the access need to
be grounded in better analysis on trends
in Kabul ization and its impact on
people and communities better and more
gender sensitive monitoring the research
policy reviews and systematic reporting
are all necessary to mobilize public
opinion and ensure better governance of
Kabul ization the volcanism encourage
all institutions and networks to
collaborate and invest in broad based
research on the social dimension and
globalization networks of national
regional and international institutions
can build the capacity needed to address
different aspects of conversation in
coherent way in conclusion I would like
to encourage you to continue open and
critical research teaching and
instruction in your various expert areas
and departments I encourage you to share
your information with the entire
international community many of the
leading academic institutions of the
word are located here in New York
including your Columbia University you
are in the position ever created
reads in the worldwide academic
community and this brings with the
greatest responsibility I trust in you
many thanks for your attention